is you take normally you take with the  knight here here you take with the rook  and the point is now that i tell you  rookie four right you know what i mean  right  yes yes no i of course yeah but uh  how did han get into it yeah that that's  the big question yeah and apparently a  move ago he was doing really really well  if he made the right decision there but  i i guess he just blundered rook takes  e4 and now he will just lose because you  it's a full pawn and here just to show  our viewers what the point is the point  is queen takes f7 here yes which is  unbelievably beautiful but it's a motif  which existed for a while but here  specifically you need to have knight  takes before check this is why you're  taking with the rook king of six knight  e4 king f5 g4 check  in takes e4 rookie one made  this is  stunningly beautiful  but also you can even choose sorry  yeah yeah it's not yeah  no the reason why i paused yeah because  i was under incredible shock yet that  oh my